you probably already know about Android
Studios life templates abbreviations
displayed as code completion options
that insert a template add snippet into
your code there are dozens of life
templates available in Android studio
but did you know you can create your own
dynamic live templates if your least
favorite piece of boilerplate code
hasn't yet been templatized it's easy to
create your own live template here we're
saving a shared preference it's a common
pattern where typically only the key
name and value vary it's also not
uncommon to forget to call apply let's
copy this code go to the preferences
menu navigate to editor then live
templates then select Android and choose
to add a new live template enter an
abbreviation that will be used as
shortcut and a helpful description then
we'll paste in our code fully qualify
the class paths and replace the parts of
our code snippet that will be different
each time with variables we'll be able
to tab through these when entering
values
this template is applicable within the
context of a Java statement when we type
a resource string name we wanted to
offer us order completion options
with our life template defined we can
start typing the abbreviation selected
from the auto completion hint by
pressing tab and it pastes in a snippet
enter each value tabbing between them
and you're done more code with fewer
keystrokes thanks to Android studio live
templates